رسائل وعدها حملتها القاذفه الامريكيه
التي حلقت فوق اجواء شبه الجزيره الكوريه
استعداد للرد بسرعه وبشكل ساحق على اي
استفزاز كوري شماليه قاذفه باثنين وخمسين
المصممه لحمل اسلحه نوويه رافقتها مقاتلات
امريكيه وكوريه جنوبيه في تدريب المشترك
رغم
شذبيان لمثل هذه المناورات ووصفها بانها
معاديه فما هي هذه القاذفات التي ارسلتها
واشنطن عبر المجال الجوي الكوري الجنوبيه
قاذفات
52 هي عنصر اساسي في قوه سلاح الجو
الامريكي قامت بمئات الطلعات الاستراتيجيه
خلال حرب فيتنام واسقطت اكثر من 15 طنا من
القنابل ابرز مميزاتها قدرتها على الطيران
بحموله كبيره من الق الدخائر كما شاهدنا
منذ قليل تبلغ 35 طنا وتمتلك مدى تشغيليا
يزيد عن 14 الف كيلو متر بدون اعاده
التزود بالوقود الجويه هي ايضا قادره على
حمله صواريخ رؤوس نوويه وصواريخ باليستيه
لقصف اهداف من مسافه مئات الكيلومترات ان
قاذفه باثنين وخمسين تمثل مزيجا من
التكنولوجيا الحديثه وايضا القديمه ويبلغ
عمرها الافتراضي نحو 30 عاما
[موسيقى]